hi Bill I'm Matt from Mexico and I want
to know what would a universal super
intelligent designer be like Thank You
Matthew
buenas Dias I don't I don't know what a
super intelligent / being would be like
people have speculated that there is an
entity that has a plan for your life and
in the u.s. anyway this we use the
English word god for this guy and if
that's true it's a lot of loose ends you
know so I'm not sure what the super
intelligent entity would be up to but to
give it to give you something to think
about in contrast the reason you and I
are here is because of evolution we a
result of millennia of about four and a
half billion years of evolution on earth
now life started in three-and-a-half
billion years ago with billions of years
of evolution and evolution doesn't work
that way there is not a super
intelligent entity at the top directing
things instead things come into being
through nature in our case on earth from
sunlight the spin of the earth and the
primordial warmth of the earth this this
energy induced chemical reactions to
take place that led to things that could
reproduce and then reproduce better and
better after that and it was bottom-up
the things that fit in the best
with the situation around them the
environment this from 3 and 1/2 billion
years ago to today not the things that
lift the most weights in the gym the
thing that fits in the best led to this
expression the survival of the fittest
and you and I are here because we're
good enough we are not super I don't
think doesn't seem to be there's no
evidence to support the idea that we
were designed by a super intelligent
designer
instead we're good enough to be here if
we weren't designed by a super
intelligent designer I mean wouldn't the
plumbing be a little different wouldn't
we have made some different choices
about things would we have six fingers
we have a bigger brain why would I
forget stuff why wouldn't I have super
eyesight why would why would I need
glasses later in life and so on so
that's a cool question but for me it it
fills me with reverence because because
you can ask it you and I are made of
primordial Stardust we are somehow at
least one of the ways that the universe
knows itself
that's a great question Matthew Garcias
carry on